what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar
and recently a lot of you guys have been
asking me to make more seven deadly sins
content
and i did recently drop a video about
the son of bond
side story the twist at the end was
absolutely insane so definitely check
that out if you haven't already
link in the description but another
topic that i've wanted to talk about for
a long time
is the ending of the seven deadly sins
and how the ending could
or maybe even should have been different
i've had some strong opinions about this
ever since the manga ended and i know
that a lot of you guys have strong
opinions as well
so let's talk about it before we get
started i want to thank
raid shadow legends for sponsoring this
video i think that pretty much everyone
has heard about raid by now and that
makes sense since the game has
25 million downloads and over 1 million
daily players i've been playing it for
over a year and what keeps me interested
is their massive active community
and their constant updates raid has one
of the biggest
and most helpful online communities so
if you ever thought about trying this
game
now is a great time to start if you need
helpful resources to get you going or
you just want to be part of an
active and vibrant gaming community raid
has a massive presence on youtube
twitch discord reddit and other
platforms
raid just released a huge champion
update that tweaks and rebalances
20 different champions to make pvp arena
battles even more competitive
and if that's not enough the forge just
came out so now you can save time and
start crafting top
quality artifacts and competing right
away so what are you waiting for
go to the video description click on the
special links and if you're a new player
you will receive
100 000 silver 50 gems 10 mystery shards
and
one free champion slasher look how cool
slasher is
and you can get them right now for free
you will find your extra rewards here
in your inbox for the next 30 days only
so
act now link in the description raid is
free to play
on mobile and pc finally this video
will of course contain seven deadly sins
manga spoilers i am talking about the
final arcs of the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned by the way
before making this video i reached out
to my followers on twitter and instagram
for their takes on how the manga
should have ended and i will include
some of my favorite responses
in this video if you want to be included
in a future video
be sure to follow me on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar now in terms of the last
few arcs of the manga
most people including me seem to really
like the new holy war arc
and esterosa slash mael is probably the
best villain in the entire series
the issues that most people had with the
ending of the manga
came in the following two arcs the demon
king arc
and the king of chaos arc the demon king
arc features the demon king possessing
the body of meliotis and then when the
demon king is defeated both on the
inside and on the outside
it appears as if the big battle is over
however
after he is expelled from eliotis's body
the demon king manages to possess
zeldras and then the battle against
demon king zeldris continues for many
more chapters
there were definitely quite a few people
who thought that the whole demon king's
zelda's part was
unnecessary they felt that the battle
against the demon king in meliotis body
should have been the end of it i can see
where these people are coming from
although to be fair after the demon king
was defeated and expelled from eliot's
body
there were a lot of people who were
disappointed that the demon king could
be defeated so quickly and easily
after all that build up so it seems like
no matter what nakaba does he can't
please everybody and personally i felt
that the zelda's part of this arc
was perfectly fine this second part of
the arc demonstrated that the demon king
was a stubborn
and resilient villain and that he is
willing to destroy both of his sons for
his
own selfish ends this second part of the
arc also gave us the single biggest and
most heartbreaking
death in the entire series the death
of big daddy sunshine our boy
escanor in terms of eskanor's role in
this arc and his eventual death
i have mixed feelings on the one hand
this arc provided a lot of character
development for escondur
and his ultimate sacrifice really
cemented the physical and spiritual
chadliness of big daddy sunshine i mean
even before he got sunshine back from
mael
escanor in his weak human form risked
his life to protect the holy knights
from one of the camara endura seeds
this scene shows us that even without
sunshine escanor
is a true hero he didn't need this
incredible power to be brave and to risk
his life to protect his friends
even in his seemingly weak and squeamish
human form
escanor is still a chad in this scene
eskner also mentions that even in his
sunshine form he still feels
pain and he says that when he fought
meliodus he felt an immeasurable amount
of pain
it was so painful that it nearly killed
him
this revelation allows us to appreciate
escanor
even more when he was in his daytime
form eskanor
always seemed so cocky and
indestructible
but in reality the power of sunshine did
not make him immune to pain
in fact he suffered tremendous pain
especially during his fight with
meliotis
but he was able to withstand it because
of his unbelievable determination
and resilience if anything this makes me
respect escanor
even more but as impressed as i was with
eskanor at this point in the story
i was equally disappointed in my l after
being the badass villain of an entire
arc
and after proving himself to be one of
the strongest characters in the entire
series
mael completely chickens out when it
comes time to fight the demon king
he agrees to give the power of sunshine
back to escanor so that escanor can go
and fight
but mael himself refuses to take part in
the fight because he says that the demon
king is just too
strong really man really now i totally
get that the plot
needed escanor to get sunshine back so
nakaba had to come up with some reason
as to why eskanor is going to be using
sunshine instead of mael
but come on there had to be a better way
to make this
happen they didn't have to do miles so
dirty and make him look like a total
wuss bag
this one brief scene really destroys our
image of mile as a character
and that is why it bugs me so much but
at the end of the day mile is not one of
the main characters so
let's move on when esquinor ultimately
sacrifices himself
in the fight against the demon king and
dies as a result of overusing sunshine
and
overwhelming his body it is truly a
heartbreaking moment
eschanor's sacrifice really brought home
how strong the bond between the seven
deadly sins is
and how unbreakable their friendship has
become the merlin kiss
at the very end of escanor's life was
also absolutely amazing
and it was as beautiful as it was tragic
eskanor's death
really added a lot of maturity to the
story even though the vast majority of
us
wanted to see eskanor and merlin get
together and have a happy ending
it definitely sucks that so many other
characters who were supposed to be dead
came back to life from important
characters like elaine and
arthur to completely unimportant
characters like veronica and freaking
vivian and yet big daddy sunshine
himself
had to be one of the few characters who
died for real
i know that a lot of people wanted
escondar to somehow come back like so
many other seven deadly sins characters
but as much as it hurts us and as much
as we would definitely trade someone
like vivian for escanor
the fact that esquinor really died added
maturity and seriousness to the story
and that has its own value overall i was
still okay with the manga
up to this point and even though it was
hard to cope with eskanor's death
i accepted it as a necessary development
that made the story
more mature for me the real issues begin
once we get to the final major arc in
the story the king
of chaos arc this arc takes place right
after the defeat of the demon king
and the death of escanor merlin the only
sin
whose true motivations had not yet been
fully revealed
transports the sins back to lake
salisbury
there she brings king arthur back from
the dead
and resurrects him as the king of chaos
i don't have a problem with the arc up
to this point the seven deadly sins is
heavily inspired by arthurian legend
and so bringing king arthur back to life
makes a lot of sense
in fact i thought that chaos power was
actually really
cool and it had been foreshadowed
earlier on in the story so again
all of this made sense to me i even
liked the inclusion of the lady of the
lake
a magical being brought from chaos that
we met in the previous arc
the lady of the lake plays a significant
role in arthurian legend
so again all good up to this point but
then we arrive at the first
big issue with this arc and that is
merlin and her true motivations
the lady of the lake reveals that merlin
has been hiding the truth about chaos
power from the sins for this
entire time that is because as a child
merlin
fell in love with meliotis because he
had saved her from the wizards of bel
alwyn who only wanted to experiment on
her and use her for her magical talents
because meliotis was the only one who
saw her as a person
and not just as some magical tool merlin
fell hopelessly in love with meliotis
but as we all know meliotis was already
in love with elizabeth
so merlin realized that she could never
stand a chance with meliotis
in order to fill this empty void in her
heart
she dedicated her entire life to one
purpose
resurrecting the power of chaos and this
is an ancient power that had been sealed
away by the demon king
and the supreme deity in pursuit of this
goal merlin was even willing to betray
the seven deadly sins such as when she
decided to reactivate
elizabeth's curse and this part about
merlin and her true motivations
really rubbed me the wrong way are you
really going to tell me that this
mysterious and epically cool
female wizard did everything she did for
the past 3000 years just because she
needed to fill a void in her heart
left by her unrequited love for meliotis
i mean really
meliotis is already loved by elizabeth
and zanery
and diane was into him for years before
she finally fell for king
so did we really need a fourth woman in
the story to be in love with meliotis
don't get me wrong i would totally get
it if merlin fell in love with him back
when she first met him because he saved
her
and treated her as an actual person
instead of some magical experiment
but for her to stay in love with him for
over 3000
years knowing that he is meant to be
with elizabeth just rubs me the wrong
way
now we all know that love is crazy and
you can't choose who you fall in love
with and all of that stuff
but still i would have been so much
happier if merlin could have just gotten
over meliodas
just like the end did so that merlin
could finally give eskanor a chance
and that whole thing about merlin
pursuing chaos power
just as some sort of distraction from
her love for meliotis
and then her being willing to even
potentially put her friends in danger
in the pursuit of that goal i don't know
it just doesn't quite fit
to me now if there had been some bigger
reason like say if chaos power was the
only thing that could defeat the supreme
deity
then i could see merlin pursuing it
because she knows that eventually they
will have to take on the supreme deity
but
this whole idea of pursuing chaos just
out of curiosity or just as a
distraction from a broken heart
i didn't like it and speaking of the
supreme deity
let's talk about the villain of the king
of chaos ark
i'm of course referring to kath palug
and i have to say that i did actually
like
the cath twist this little creature was
always so mysterious
and then suddenly having it turn on
arthur and become a villain
was something that really shocked me in
a good way i also thought that kath's
final form was really cool
it was a dope design and so overall i
don't have a problem with kath
as a villain but i do have a problem
with kath
as the final villain of the entire story
to me kath always felt like a side
villain
a lead up villain to a much more epic
and dangerous threat
the cath fight was basically a quick
training arc for arthur
as he was learning to harness and
control the power of chaos
i was expecting that once kath was
defeated we would learn that the next
villain and the real final villain would
be the supreme deity
that would have made perfect sense from
a narrative perspective the demon king
and the supreme deity were always built
up
as two major villains and then as the
story went on we spent so much time
focusing on the demon king
and hardly any time was spent on the
supreme deity
i was thinking that the sins needed
chaos power in order to defeat the
supreme deity and after cath was
defeated and
arthur learned to use chaos power the
sins and arthur would venture to the
celestial realm to take on the supreme
deity
this would give elizabeth a chance to
confront her mother it would give us a
major
epic battle worthy of a series finale
and it would actually answer all of the
lingering questions about the supreme
deity
who up to this point had remained a big
mystery it only made sense that after we
spent so much time on the demon king
we would eventually get to the supreme
deity especially since both of these
overpowered beings were responsible for
the holy wars and for the curses placed
on meliodas and elizabeth it wasn't just
a demon king who was the problem
and his defeat on its own doesn't solve
all of britannia's issues
if anything now that the balance of
power has been disrupted
the supreme deity could be more
dangerous than ever
and yet the story seemed to completely
ignore the supreme deity
and the celestial realm and after the
cath palug fight
the manga ended we got those final few
chapters after the time skips which i
actually liked quite a bit
but that chaos arc really felt rushed
and
incomplete merlin's true intentions the
supreme deity
chaos power and the lady of the lake and
her role in the whole story
all of these aspects of the story felt
incomplete when the manga ended
also how are they gonna do that to hawks
mama she just gets consumed by arthur
and disappears from the story
after everything she did for the sins
not cool man
not cool now it is possible that the
sequel manga is planning to cover the
supreme deity and that is why we didn't
get to see her in the original manga
and from the lancelot side story it is
clear that the lady of the lake
is definitely going to be relevant to
the sequel so maybe the same will be the
case
for the supreme deity if that's true
then fine
but that doesn't change the fact that
the original manga ended with
kath as the final major villain and that
was just
underwhelming in my opinion so for me
personally the biggest
issues with the ending were merlin's
true intentions and her flimsy
justifications for wanting to resurrect
chaos even at the cost of putting her
friends in danger
and the ignoring of the supreme deity
while elevating a side character like
kath palug into the final villain in the
story
if i could change the story in any way
that i wanted i definitely would have
expanded the chaos arc
included an epic final battle against
the supreme deity
and i would have fleshed out merlin's
true intentions more thoroughly
but those are just my own thoughts on
the ending and i've been thinking about
this stuff ever since the manga came to
a conclusion many months ago
now let's see how you guys thought the
series should have ended over on twitter
and instagram and of course if you want
to be featured in future videos like
this one don't forget to follow me
at anime uproar over on twitter there
were a lot of comments about lord twigo
and how he should have been revealed as
the mastermind behind the entire story
even nox taku got in on the action
because
of course he did but little do these
commenters know that lord tuigo's true
purpose
stretches far beyond the scope of the
seven deadly sins manga
he is clearly a trans-dimensional and
multiversal entity
and any attempt to understand his true
intentions and motivations through the
lands of the seven deadly sins alone
is absolutely futile you should know
that by now knux
come on man we also had comments like
this one from vtsukuya about the need to
explore chaos power
in greater detail and also the need to
bring the supreme deity into the story
as the final villain
i mentioned these points in the video as
well so i totally agree
with this sentiment we had comments like
this one from juan mas suggesting that
the entire king of chaos arc was
unnecessary i agree that this arc felt
rushed and incomplete
but if we didn't have this arc at all
then we would still have a lot of
unsolved mysteries
unanswered questions and incomplete
segments of the story for example
merlin's true motivations would not have
been revealed at all
and we would still be wondering about a
lot of things like chaos
hawks mama and of course the supreme
deity although the chaos arc didn't
actually help us when it comes to the
supreme deity
my take is that the chaos arc should
have been included but it should have
been expanded
or maybe an extra arc should have been
added that dealt with the supreme deity
shu chiha echoes the idea that we needed
to learn more about merlin and the
supreme deity and
hsk points out that it would have been
cool to see the celestial realm
and to learn more about hawk's mama i
have to agree on these points as well
we might still get more about this stuff
in the sequel but i think it would have
been better to include it in the main
story
over on instagram we also had a number
of comments saying that the supreme
deity should have been the final villain
like this one from luffy king 355 we had
multiple comments saying that esquinor
should not have died or that he should
have been revived
such as these comments by taki xtaki
benny reds and
nate nightingale there were also some
comments like this one by lame head park
beth about the possibility of the
supreme deity being involved
in the sequel and i think that's
definitely possible
but i still agree with the people who
wanted to see the supreme deity as the
final villain in the original story
nevertheless i am excited for the sequel
and i will definitely give it a chance
huge thanks to everyone who gave their
input on twitter and instagram
and feel free to let me know what you
guys think down in the comments below
how do you guys think that the seven
deadly sins manga should have ended
were there any issues that particularly
rubbed you the wrong way
and what would you like to see in the
sequel let me know
down below if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more seven deadly synths
content and sequel content right here on
the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime opera
or maybe you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you